[Music]
unfriended is a cyber horror film taking
place entirely on a teenager's computer
screen we see this entire film play out
over Skype conference video calls
iMessage chats and Facebook messages the
film depicts a group of teenagers who
are all friends on a Skype conference
call who are all aware of someone they
used to know who committed suicide now
this person named Laura Barnes was
bullied into doing this because of a
video that was filmed of her drunk at a
party and cyber bullying got so intense
for her that she actually took her own
life and supposedly she might just be
haunting their computers to get back at
them yeah I can't wait for the sequel
hidden from newsfeed so I went into this
film with pretty low expectations I do
like horror films when they're good I
like originality I like unique ways of
storytelling I actually found this movie
unsettling and very unnerving and I
think a large reason that that was
actually because of the realism depicted
by the filmmaker they used the real
Skype sound effects the real Facebook
sound effects the real iMessage sound
effects all the little details like when
a facebook notification happens and it
happens the top right corner of your
screen or the fact that she has a whole
bunch of tabs open in her internet I
mean all of these little things lent to
a very realistic feel when you are
looking at this girl's computer screen
the other thing I actually loved about
this movie was the very subtle way and
still realistic way of learning things
about this girl who has this computer
open she'll sometimes start to type
replies to this thing this entity and
then she'll delete it before posting it
and as she types those replies then
changes her mind and deletes them and
type something else you learn things
about her personality and that was a
very clever way of telling this story
because in a way this is a very
low-budget contained thriller contain
thriller as I'm sure you guys know is
like you know a whole bunch of people in
a room like say 12 Angry Men 12 jurors
in one room trying to decide if
someone's guilty or not guilty this is
in a way a contained thriller it takes
place almost entirely during a Skype
conversation now you might think that's
going to get boring the movies around 80
minutes long and believe it or not I was
never bored and I think a lot of it had
to do with that realism that was too
acted like I said because they're Skype
videos weren't perfect 1080p quality
like they are in most films they glitch
out the audio from there speaking
sometimes isn't in sync with their
mouths I mean that's how it is in real
life and that realism from all the sound
effects and the actual applications that
we're so used to using made it very
unsettling because when you really think
about it we rely on some of those things
to work and all of a sudden when
something is inside your computer not
allowing you to close out of your Skype
not allowing you to turn your computer
off not allowing you to close out videos
that are being shoved in your face and
once this thing starts to turn these
friends against each other that's when
the movie went to another level entirely
the idea of this thing bringing out the
dirty secrets of all of these friends
into the open made it kind of
psychological and took it beyond just
the gimmick movie that I was expecting
and made it a lot deeper because it
really explores the internet generation
of today and how sometimes the cruelty
and the lack of empathy of people on the
internet who have anonymity can actually
be more frightening than a guy with a
knife and I think the fact that this
movie is actually making me think that
deep about its subplot when it's a movie
that takes place entirely on a
teenager's computer screen that's kind
of commendable now I've been told by a
few friends that the movie the den is
very similar which is available on
Netflix I don't know I have not seen it
so as far as I know this isn't the first
time a movie like this has been made but
there are aspects of it that I can
definitely see being imitated especially
for the fact that I'm assuming this
movie was made for next to nothing as
for issues with the movie almost every
character is like a horror stereotype
there's the funny stoner guy there's the
more promiscuous characters who are more
sexually active than the more innocent
girls and then you know it's like there
are character tropes that are all
throughout horror and they're definitely
there in this movie and there's jump
scares galore from time to time where
sound effects just happen and but I got
to say the most startling elements of
this movie to me were when like
characters would notice something and
they're just staring at it and they're
not saying what they're looking at and
that's just absolutely unnerving to me
in fact the movie it follows that I
recently saw and really enjoyed to me
the scariest parts of that movie were
when you didn't actually see it and
people were just like it's right there I
can see it and that takes the Jaws
element as
well a lot of the scariest parts of Jaws
were because they didn't show the shark
and that's definitely something this
movie is benefiting from because there
are moments in which you don't really
see what these characters are seeing
because it's all on skype and you use
your imagination which makes it more
startling now I saw this movie with five
of my friends two of us liked it and
myself included the other three didn't
so that should probably tell you
something I think this movie is going to
be very dividing because it is
definitely a movie that audiences are
gonna go to and some will hate this
movie because it's just a computer
screen if you're expecting the Hollywood
eyes treatment here with lots of shots
and cool action sequences you're not
going to get it I'm sure a lot of people
will probably hate this movie and that's
perfectly fine if it's not for you
that's cool there's nothing wrong with
that and I swear to you this is not a
belated April Fool's joke I actually
really enjoyed this movie doesn't open
for around 16 days but if you guys want
to interesting in different time with
the movies and a very unorthodox
approach to storytelling unfriended is
not that bad actually in my opinion I'm
gonna give unfriended a B+ it follows is
a considerably more well-made film with
much better characters if you're looking
for that kind of movie you want horror
you want some thrills and you want
better characters go see it follows if
you're interested in a different
approach to storytelling and you don't
mind as much about the gimmick of this
computer screen and all that check out
unfriended as well but it follows is
definitely a better movie but I gave
them the same grade because they both do
what they're trying to do and they
actually do it very well it's really
nice that between the babadook and it
follows and now this movie I've actually
enjoyed some horror films lately I
really think some people are actually
listening to the fans out there and
making some better horror films with
different approaches to storytelling and
that's awesome guys if you have seen
this movie or if you plan on seeing it
or its eventual sequels unsubscribed
unfollowed and blocked let us know what
you think below thank you so much as
always for watching guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck man eyes
[Music]